quand on parle d'un changement qui est
quand même un changement historique la
date du cas décembre était en circuit au
calendrier d'Emma Québec depuis
septembre dernier lorsque santé Canada a
approuvé sa demande pour des dons de
sang plus inclusifs
dorénavant l'homosexualité n'est plus un
critère d'exclusion pour les hommes
qu'on souhaite hétérosexuel bisexuel
pansexuel mettez l'étiquette que vous
voulez l'évaluation du risque se fait
sur la base des comportements
individuels les personnes qui
déclareront à voir un nouveau partenaire
sexuel depuis moins de trois mois ou
encore plusieurs partenaires devront
tout simplement répondre à des questions
supplémentaires avant de pouvoir donner
leur sang
qui était injuste la science a tranché
confirme le docteur Martin à champagne
au terme d'un long combat pour les
droits des personnes gays ont démontré
que le don ça pouvait être tout à fait
sécuritaire le risque transfusionnel due
à un virus comme l'immunodéficience
humaine apparaître maintenant
négligeable il était soumis à moins de 1
sur 10 millions
dans le quartier Guy de Montréal la
nouvelle est salué c'est un qui nous
ouverture d'esprit pour les jeunes il y
avait une discrimination là-dessus je
trouve que c'est une avancée oui puis en
même temps il y a tellement de besoins
au niveau des dons de sang on a besoin
de 1000 donneurs par jour quels effets
aura ce nouvel assouplissement sur la
réserve de sang des Québec si on regarde
le Royaume-Uni qui a été vraiment le
premier pays à implanter une approche
non genre il y a pas eu d'impact Laurent
Paul Ménard voit toutefois dans cette
approche une importante avancée sociale
un avis que partage de nombreux
Québécois comme ces donneuses régulières
je trouve que c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour tout le monde pour toute
la communauté toutes les communautés
confondues ici a dit Yacine